[Music]
[Music]
I'm putting together a team people with
special abilities
stop right there I'm in you are just
like that
yeah I need friends the flash joins
forces with Batman Wonder Woman Aquaman
and Cyborg and in doing so we become the
greatest superhero team ever Oh awesome
let's talk about the dynamic Bruce is
actively trying to find these
superhumans that he believes are out
there this is the first time after many
years that she starts working in a team
again to make the world a better place
there's a very interesting team dynamic
half-man half-machine cyborg is the
perfect combination of Technology and
the human heart Aquaman he kills from
two different worlds he's human a nice
Atlanta
flash has the ability to experience time
more slowly honestly I'm having too much
fun
don't engage alone we do this together
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
good morning after the death of Superman
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream it was the
end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker
we're asking people we'd unknown to risk
their lives strongman of strongest alone
never heard that it's my saying that's
the opposite of what the saying is
divided we are not enough
[Music]
worldly Superman
[Music]
made him promise
why I brought you together ride ain't
over yet man
[Music]
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
oh sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah I sorted me it's it's so
cool
[Music]